it's wonderful to be here in this
beautiful city it's wonderful to take
part again and and and one of the great
intellectual centers of contemporary
life the Nexus Institute such a pleasure
to be here among people whom it is an
enormous pleasure and honor to know so I
will not solve the questions that Rob
has broached but here's what I have to
say about them modern Western societies
are not organisms that thrive or perish
is one thing one mind one experience
they are compacts based on the
expectation that those charged with
responsibilities will carry them out in
good faith and crucially that those who
are relatively powerful will not
seriously abuse exploit or simply
neglect those who are relatively
vulnerable democracy is profound mutual
courtesy an ethos of mutual respect and
is in this sense deeply spiritual it
should never be forgotten that jefferson
asserts human equality in the terms of
the biblical creation narrative the
dignity conferred on each individual by
his creator is to be acknowledged as
inalienable worthy of all respect
failure in this regard has always
afflicted American democracy and every
other democracy of which I have any
knowledge this spiritual failure has now
become conspicuous consequential
shameless and in America organized under
the auspices of the Republican Party it
startles me that I feel justified in
saying such a thing it opposed me that
it is in urgent need of being said but
the importance of this deviation from
the first given of the American
democratic order this apostasy so to
speak by a wealthy establishment
presence is truly threatening
to trust one another with our ballots
and then to accept the decisions
reflected in them has always depended on
an ethic of mutual respect which for the
moment is not to be assumed it is hard
to imagine what will restore the
integrity of the system I've ever no
spiritual awakening which could happen
since old white people like me are
trudging toward the exits
demographically speaking bearing away a
great part of the fearfulness and
sanctimonious nough that has written our
politics there are vast cohorts of young
people and newly aroused in enfranchised
minorities for whom the founding
documents are authoritative and
beautiful we can begin our recovery by
respecting them an easy first step
because they are eminently deserving of
respect decline emerges as an idea very
often perhaps continuously though it
finds greater or lesser degrees of
response from one iteration to the next
those who raise the alarm in the
intervals when there is little consensus
to support this view of things are later
seen as prophets they add to the chorus
or to the literature to be deployed when
such consensus does begin to emerge if
historically a growing sense of decline
precedes catastrophe perhaps this is
true because the idea predisposes the
culture to nihilism and also to the
desperate battle against nihilism which
is the other side of the same coin these
two apparently contrary movements act as
accelerants two excitements that arise
between them because they both proceeded
from categorical and very negative
assumptions about people in general the
masses as they are often called in this
context this low estimation means that
no vision is offered of a future an
ongoing life for the culture that people
in general could wish to have a part in
I could be describing the collapse of a
democracy or I could be describing the
means by which a democracy can survive
and overcome the great vulnerable
by which democracy is always threatened
it may not be very long before the
matter is determined one way or the
other our government has been based in a
greater degree than any of us were aware
on norms and customs unenforceable
deference to precedent and restraint in
the face of opposition our incumbent is
intent on remaking the office to suit
his own character and is both limited
and protected by a tradition of respect
for the office of president respect
which he seems not to share
when norms are violated with impunity
will they function as norms again
thereafter will the standards of conduct
they have supported be changed by the
attempts that are likely to come to
enforce them by legislation assuming a
restoration of something like normalcy
in other words will a complex
institutional stability be compromised
changed or lost leaving us with in
America we cannot foresee and will not
have chosen many essential things are in
a state of true indeterminacy so it
seems we are on our way to learning how
our politics live in our civilization
how we understand our problems and what
resources we bring to mitigating them if
we subscribe to decline as an
interpretation of our problems our
democracy will indeed fail the concept
declined by implication takes a former
state of things to be good and evil to
be those tendencies perceived at least
as departing from it evil is a word I'm
generally reluctant to use but in the
context of cultural pessimism it evokes
precisely the nature of what is to be
feared and resisted in the dissolution
these people think they see to call if
anything evil is to lift it out of the
ordinary the secular to assume in it a
special energy that places it beyond the
strategies of reason and good intent and
the demands hyper alertness and recourse
to very extraordinary defenses this idea
of evil is holiness infer
seyton loose in a godless world speak of
this devil and he is very likely to
appear I do not believe I cannot imagine
that any human being could be without a
spirit a soul I believe as a matter of
faith as well as observation the
spirituality arises out of the
individual spirit soul II by the grace
of God through difficulty despite
neglect in the absence of help and
approval in tactful or tentative silence
and secrecy as surely as in the
restitution recitation of any Creed I
believe that human beings have an
endlessly demonstrated tendency to
refuse to acknowledge the Spirit in
themselves and crucially and culturally
selected others slaves aliens women Jews
heretics enemies real or perceived the
blindness they induce in themselves
releases them from the confirm the felt
constraints of justice mercy and
reverence and monsters them individually
and as societies this is a brief history
of humanity's crimes against itself
American Puritans ancestors of my
tradition the people who gave us
Thanksgiving did not celebrate Christmas
which they considered a pagan festival
but they did in a larger sense celebrate
the Incarnation the faith that God
himself could pass unnoticed in this
world an ordinary man
according to Calvin when physically
marred by poverty and labor who might he
not be he told us who he was the hungry
the sick the imprisoned the stranger I
believe there was once a convention in
the liberal state that there is courtesy
old to those with whom he explicitly
identified well society giveth in
society taketh away but for Christians
the Incarnation changed the world in one
great particular we know what we do whom
we slight insult ignore again
parable that is our faith would tell us
that the spirit is always real always
present waiting to be seen
thank you
[Music]
you